being an activist for indigenous peoples
and representing for queer people as
well how do you represent for yourself
how do you observe for others and stand
up for everybody right now in this
moment I don't think this year is how
anybody imagined that 2020 would go but
I think right now during indigenous
peoples History Month and also during
Pride Month that it's really a time to
like to honor our ancestors or queer
ancestors or after our indigenous
ancestors and black allies throughout
history who stood beside us in our play
and I think now is also the time for us
to lend our support to the black
community with all of this momentum
that's happening and and the fight for
change there it's actually within our
reach now as a performer you've been out
front representing for a long time and
fighting for a lot of time have you seen
the difference that you've made I can
name on maybe maximum two hands like
queer indigenous actors who are out
there who are out who are playing their
roles who are playing indigenous roles
and so I mean it's definitely opening
doors this hasn't happened before it's
frustrating it's exhausting in a lot of
ways but there's also like a an inherent
energy that comes with it a fuel to
fight for this because there's no other
option seeing the support from my
community on my reserve where I grew up
and also all of the different
communities across North America has
been really grounding and it constantly
is reminding me what we're fighting for
you can see debri right now and the
binge were the first season of
supernatural series the order before
it's highly anticipated second season
premieres later this month the improv
troupe we are a sacred Brotherhood
gender neutral collective anointed to
fight dark magic with the power dude
we're werewolves I think season two
we're all actually really nervous going
into it because like we had gone through
comic-con and we saw how much it blew up
and we had no idea what kind of impact
it would have it was on the homepage of
Netflix because then we're like a small
Canadian
werewolf show yeah like set the pace for
a really fun season and I think it's
also like a great show space ISM from
everything that's happening in the world